The Joe Rogan Experience so um James
Webb James Webb Telescope and James yeah
there's been a lot of media uh reports
suggesting that the findings of the
James Webb Telescope have undermined the
case for The Big Bang or the Big Bang
Theory
but there's an interesting backstory on
this most of these media reports were
based on the writings of a single uh
physics researcher named Eric Lerner
who's been since 1990 kind of carrying a
torch to refute the Big Bang
and
Lerner
in one of his his articles
quoted a University of Kansas
astrophysicist uh saying that she stays
up late at night wondering if based on
the on the the James Webb that
everything that we know is turning out
to be false
turns out that that researcher uh that
astrophysicist disclaimed his use of the
quote explained that he took it
completely out of context that she was
talking about theories of Galaxy
formation not about whether or not there
had been a big bang and not about
whether or not the universe is expanding
as we would expect so he's confirmation
bias yeah and and in a sense also taking
somebody way out of context to make a
point of his own you know he he misused
the quotation on purpose apparently
apparently um so here's here's uh and
there have been a number of leading
astrophysicists in fact people who would
like you know to know more about this
I'd recommend the uh what Brian Keating
from University of California San Diego
great astrophysicist has been writing
about this and but here's the short
story I wrote a an op-ed in the daily
wired just distilling some of this stuff
um what what the James Webb Telescope is
able to do is to in fact was what it was
constructed to do was to detect
extremely long wavelength radiation
stuff that's outside the visible range I
call it Uber redshifted that it's
actually in the infrared range is the
more uh accurate physics uh term so it's
looking for very long wavelength uh
radiation coming from galaxies that are
very very far out there now why would it
be looking for that well because if the
universe is expanding as we would expect
based on The Big Bang Theory then the
the radiation coming from things very
very far out in space and therefore very
far back in time should be very
stretched out more stretched out than
stuff that's closer at hand
uh so the James Webb was constructed in
hopes of detecting that type of
radiation if it existed it's not
assuming that it necessarily would but
it would be a way of confirming the
expansion of the universe has been going
on for a very long time and in order to
do that the NASA people created some
amazing technology they super cooled the
detection technology or the detection
apparatus to I think five six seven
degrees above absolute zero so that the
heat coming off of the instrument itself
was not creating infrared that would
that would interfere
and what they were in fact able to
detect from these very ancient very
distant galaxies was super
redshifted radiation Uber redshifted
stuff out in the infrared and were able
on the basis of that to synthesize
images of these very very distant remote
galaxies now the very fact that they
were able to do that
confirms that you have that what you
would expect on the basis of The Big
Bang Theory that you would that the
amount of red shift that you would
expect to be
present if in fact the Galaxies have
been expanding throughout that vast
stretch of time was in fact present and
was detected now that didn't get
reported there were what the whole Focus
was on the fact that there were galaxies
that were more mature there were more of
them early on than we would have
expected based on our theories of Galaxy
formation and so those are anomalies
that need to be addressed and have not
yet been explained as I understand it
maybe the astrophysicists have made more
progress on that in even recent recent
days but the basic picture of an
expanding Universe outward from a
beginning has not been undermined but
rather confirmed in a very dramatic way
at very great distance and with it and
for Galaxies that are a very far Look
Back Time way way back in time so I
think it's a rather dramatic
confirmation there have been many others
the cosmic background radiation that was
discovered in 1965 the Kobe radiation of
George the George Smoot discovered in
the 90s so there's been this pattern of
confirming evidence of this basic
picture of an expanding Universe out
from the beginning in in observational
astronomy from the 20s right up till now
and so that I think gives us good reason
to think best we can tell the universe
at a beginning can I pause you on that
what is the when she's discussing the
the formation of galaxies what what had
thrown that into question like what what
was about the formation of galaxies that
undermined previous ideas I'm going to
answer tentatively because I I don't
know this as well as the other that I
just described but as I understand it
it's that there were are more galaxies
that formed earlier and are more mature
than we would have expected because they
were able to do look back to 13.5 13.6
billion years ago they think the origin
of the universe is about 13.8 billion
years ago so apparently galaxies were
forming faster than we would have
expected and I think that's the anomaly
that is on the table does that just push
the timeline further back but still come
up with the data that points to the idea
of a beginning that I I've wondered that
I I don't that seems to me a logical
possibility maybe maybe the origin of
the universe was further back but it's
still you're still getting this picture
of a of a of a collapsing sphere in the
reverse direction of time back to a
point but is it possible that with
further further detection we can with
new data have a better understanding of
what is actually going on rather than
just saying it all points to this thing
because it seems like
there's there's data but it's what
you're what you're describing seems like
it's possible at least in the future to
get better detection methods yeah it's
always possible that we can change our
minds on things because science is
always provisional but there are many
stable
um
uh theories that have persisted because
of a preponderance of evidence that
points to and continues to point to the
same conclusion and I think we've had a
hundred years now where we've had
repeated new types of observations that
point towards a beginning and there were
there are two other classes of of
um two other developments and
theoretical physics that also I think
reinforce this that I also wrote about
in the book uh one is
um the the one one is the the the the
singularity theorems that Hawking and
Penrose and uh George Ellis approved in
the 1960s and 70s and then there's
something called the um board guthval
income theorem which I think is even a
tighter uh physics proof of a beginning
I think there is a loophole with the
Hawking Penrose
Ellis Singularity theorem although it's
it's I think very suggestive and highly
indicative of of the beginning let me
run it just please briefly because it's
a fun thing to think about so Hawking is
uh doing black hole physics for his PhD
in the 1960s and he's at Cambridge and
he's having these neurological symptoms
and he's he's diagnosed with ALS he gets
very very discouraged he thinks he's
going to quit and he's encouraged to
press on by uh close friends and he does
and he ends up uh writing This brilliant
thesis where he has one chapter where
he's thinking about what the
cosmologists are talking about is that
we've got this expanding universe
and if the universe is
expanding in the forward direction of
time then matter is getting more and
more diffuse over time now
um general part of his thesis involves
general relativity Einstein's theory of
gravity and according to Einstein
uh the a massive body actually curves
the fabric of space or space time so if
you're going in the forward direction of
time space is getting less and less
curved and matter more and more diffuse
but if you're going in the reverse
direction of time the matter is getting
more and more densely concentrated at
every successive point in the finite
past until again you reach a limiting
case where the matter gets so densely
concentrated that space gets so tightly
curved that it can't get any more
tightly curved it can't get any more
densely concentrated and you move
towards a point of infinite density and
infinite curvature you get to a limiting
case
now infinite curvature corresponds to
zero spatial volume
and so the picture of the origin of the
universe that sort of intuitively flows
from this is one where you get not just
matter and energy arising but space and
time come into existence at that at that
zero point
and
um he presents this in his PhD thesis uh
it's the story of this is told really
nicely in the little film the the the
the
um
uh Theory of Everything and he's fear
and trepidation getting examined but one
of his examiner they're nitpicking all
these different things but then they say
hey the idea of a of a black hole at the
beginning of the universe a space-time
Singularity this is brilliant
congratulations Dr Hawking and they
shoved the thesis book back over to him
and he's passed but one of them says now
go work out the maths and he ends up
working out the math of this intuitive
proof that he develops with uh sir Roger
Penrose with whom you have done a
wonderful interview and and George Ellis
who I've had the occasion to meet and
and so they end up producing several of
these Singularity theorems suggesting
that if general relativity is true then
there must have been a beginning this is
an independent on grounds independent of
all the things from observational
astronomy now there's a loophole with
that and that is that in the very
tiniest smidgens of space-time
um inside 10 to the minus 43rd of a
second or what they call Planck time
Quantum effects might have been such
that we would have to alter our ideas of
how gravity worked and so out of that
has come something called an Impulse or
a our different theories of what are
called quantum gravity or Quantum
cosmology and
um I think you've had some conversations
on this show about that as well sure
um in my book I show that that's that is
a possible another possible cosmological
model
but like the conclusion that the
Universe had a definite beginning I
think those models also have theistic
implications and I can explain why okay
um maybe as we bracket that okay then
the third there's a yet a third proof
though of a beginning that com by um
three physicists board Guth and
Alexander velenken and it's not based on
general relativity it's not based on
ideas of what gravity was like in the
early universe but based on ideas of
special relativity
it's a little tricky to explain easily
but basically they show that they're
again a limiting case and therefore a
definite beginning uh to to time and uh
and therefore and that it does not have
the same loophole that the The
Singularity theorems of Hawking and
Penrose so what I've said in my I what I
argue in the book is that a body of
evidence from observational astronomy
a strong indicator from theoretical
physics namely The Singularity theorems
of Hawking at all and then a very
compelling proof from board Guth and
velenken all point to the same
conclusion that as best we can tell the
universe had a beginning and I think
that's the best we can do in science but
that is a pretty weighty
um range of testimony
uh supporting the same conclusion did
you ever read any Terence McKenna I
haven't Terence kind of had a very funny
thing that he said about science he said
science wants you to believe that it's
all about measurement and reason if you
allow them one miracle
but one Miracle's the Big Bang Yes that
all things come from the most
Preposterous idea ever yeah that
everything came from nothing in one big
miracle that's right I completely
paraphrase
this was this was her Fred hoyle's
objection to the Big Bang he was he said
he was a democracy and he didn't believe
and he said nothing comes from nothing
and I did I simply refused to believe
that that the physical Universe came
from nothing physical and moreover he
said it smacks of the Genesis account
which he detested and so he rejected the
big bang and formulated this steady
state model
um that was later I think decisively
refuted by the discovery of the cosmic
background radiation his uh it happens
I've had funny coincidental meetings
with Hoyle Hermann Bondi and Thomas gold
all three of the The Architects of the
steady state model I met Bondi and Hoyle
when I was a PhD Student in Cambridge
and Hoyle held on to his dying day for
the the steady state but uh Bondi uh uh
actually we had a conversation about it
and he said that that well it turned out
that it was a brilliant idea it was a
beautiful idea just that it turned out
that everything about it was wrong and
he rejected it so uh but uh later Hoyle
had his own conversion to a kind of
quasi-theistic world view because of his
Discovery the fine-tuning parameters but
the the point is that the materialists
did not expect
to have this evidence for the beginning
Hoyle thought that you know the laws of
physics were the the first law of uh
conservation of matter and energy uh you
know matter and energy are neither
created nor destroyed except at the Big
Bang
and he didn't like that but eventually I
think the physics Community came around
there was so many indicators of that
beginning event